[Musique]
je considère et millicom ma meilleure
amie
c'est une personne merveilleuse et si
raffiné quand j'étais petit je ne pèse
comme une fleur ma femme est une énigme
elle se laisse approcher mais reste à
jamais inaccessible j'adorais les mythes
mais tous ces moments faisait pas nous
avons tous notre part d'ombré
certains le cache mieux que d'autres
qatar mon poisson rouge
il m'appelle jour et nuit donnant pour
moi et je mentais rien comme pour
il ya cinq jours emilie a disparu je me
rends compte que finalement je ne la
connaissais pas aussi bien qu 100 ml
si tu nous entends nous sommes tous très
inquiets
[Musique]